une naissance dans ce journal celle
d'une nouvelle station balnéaire sur le
littoral aquitaine c'est tour un port en
gironde cette station vient tout juste
de démarrer la première tranche de
travaux à peine achevé hourtin-port déjà
connaît un certain succès d'un abonné
jean pierre darrot nous présente la
fiche d'identité de la petite soeur de
carcans maubuisson et de lacanau océan
pour un porc issus des marées il y à 18
mois il n'y avait rien ici et perdent
incertaine mais niait de nostalgie
aujourd'hui les premiers bâtiments en
photo na bodio de ce que sera la station
les travaux vont nous emmener le 1er
juillet il fallait ouvrir
premier argument pour vendre ou encore
sa situation au bord du plus grand lac
de france l'école de voile animé par le
cpa sur un plan de s'adapter à la
pratique de la planche à voile et du
katana un port de plaisance de 400
places très largement occupé aujourd'hui
mais la spécificité dont un port c'est
la place accordée aux enfants le coeur
de la station leur appartient sur une
volonté délibérée
le slogan de la station nous avons
décidé de compléter ce qui existait déjà
en gironde lacanau loisirs sportifs car
comme me son sport santé et nous sommes
tombés sur ce thème qui nous semblent
porter nautisme enfance parce que le
cadre s'y prête
parce qu'ensuite sociologiquement
économiquement l'enfance la famille sont
des vecteurs intéressant et puis parce
qu'il s'agit d'une opération nouvelle
que lorsque l'on veut réussir une
opération nouvelle
autant ignorer d'où premières stations
en france nautisme la maison de
l'enfance ses lacs sont accueillis les
plus petits cette année les enfants âgés
de 3 à 6 ans les nourrissons dès l'an
prochain la capacité une centaine de
bambins
l'originalité de ce lieu la maison est
ouverte aux parents pour vivre autrement
avec leurs enfants
demain une piste de bicross sera
proposée aux plus valeureux
après demain c'est à dire en 87 ce sera
l'île aux enfants un territoire
privilégié pour les plus jeunes
300 lits disponibles cet été trois mille
deux cent vingt trois ans
l'investissement total au 1er juillet
environ 80 millions de francs
partiellement engagée par la commune
l'investissement est tout de même une
chose qui pèse sur le budget communal
mais enfin qui est supporter quand on
voit ce qui va nous arriver d'ici
quelques années avec cet afflux
d'estivants cet afflux touristique que
nous voyons des cette année on peut dire
que nous sommes en train de pulvériser
depuis deux ou trois jours tous les
records d'affluence que nous avons
jamais connu hourtin port bénéficie de
l'expérience de leurs aînés carcans
maubuisson en matière de gestion mais
aussi en matière de développement
beaucoup de la de l'enfance au delà
motif la qualité du site et la
sauvegarde des équilibres essentiels
demeurent des arguments de promotion